Girls, the eyebrows up.
A light powder, I want a little rouge right here.
She needs a marvelous mouth.
The hair, it's awful. It must come off.
Would you mind telling me what all this is about?
We may as well get started. Babs, get that dreadful thing off of her.
Now, wait a minute. Just a minute.
Don't! Stop!
This is my second and last encounter with you lunatics.
You just keep your hands off me, all of you.
I come here to make a simple delivery and I find myself being pillaged and plundered.
Well, I'll have no more of it.
I don't want my hair cut.
I don't want my eyebrows up or down.
I want them right where they are.
And I see no functional advantage in a marvelous mouth.
I'm leaving now.
And if anyone so much as makes a move to stop me,...
...there'll be plenty of hair cut and it won't be mine.
Bring her back here, girls, alive!